we've been through all of the rigmarole
of the pipeline all of their complicated
operations moving from local space to
world space to view space collapsing our
objects down to a 2d plane clipping them
and then generating pixels deciding
which pixels to keep them which Peaks
pixels to throw away so the main
question now is how do we color the
pixels in what what do we do with the
pixels what we generally want to do if
we're trying to replicate reality is do
some sort of lighting equations at every
pixel so for every pixel we've run a
little program that does these kind of
computations and that will given a point
on a surface the normal at that point
and some other information about the
surface maybe the material properties
and information about the light source
where the light source is relative to
the surface what color the light is what
direction the light is coming on how the
light attenuate to the sill and so forth
with all of these inputs we can finally
generate a shaded value to say well this
is well let's or it's in it's it's
facing away from the light so it's in
shade and so on and so forth the
equations that we do the computation of
the lines value at every pixel is local
it's local to the surface that we're
lighting because in all of our work that
we've done getting down to pixels we're
not really holding on to any over and
other information about this the rest of
the scene we only know about the one
object that we're working with at a time
so we only know about the pixels on the
surface of this object we don't know for
example if there is another object here
blocking the lights reaching this object
so we cannot account for that in our
simple light model at this pixel so in
all the computer graphics when you look
at them you'll often see that actually
you can see that these local light
models in action and the lack of shadow
is is quite apparent how then do we get
that information how do we get that
global
formation to augment our local light
model and for example render shadows how
do we decide that this point on the
surface is being occluded by another
object is somewhere else in the scene
and the answer to that or one solution
is to go back to our friend the depth
buffer the depth buffer as we'll
remember is a representation at every
pixel of the depth of that pixel in the
scene what we can do is we can render
the scene not from the cameras point of
view but from the point of view of the
light rather than rendering shaded
pixels however we just output the depth
buffer values so what we end up with is
a buffer of data containing the depth
per pixel depth from the position of the
light why is that useful thing to have
well what we've done really is we've
rephrase the question we're not saying
is such a pixel in light or shade we're
saying is such a pixel visible to the
light because if a pixel is visible to
the light then it's being illuminated if
it's not visible to the light
then it's in shadow it will probably be
clearer to actually cast some shadows
and this now again we got a good shadow
on that no no not really
that's a bit better isn't it right so we
have our scene a simple pyramid will
incorporate the table into this because
this is where the shadow is being cast
so the table is another 3d object in our
3d world and we want to shade a point
here so for about them not only do we
need to know properties of the surface
at this point and the normal and the
material properties in the direction of
the light and so on and so forth but we
also want to know whether it's in light
or in shade
so how do we determine that the shading
of a pixel is local and we don't have
information about the rest of the scenes
so we can't know whether or not a
certain point is being occluded by
another object in the scene we don't
know whether it's in shadow or not to
solve that problem we use a two-step
process that involves the z-buffer first
of all though we render the scene from
the point of view not of the camera but
of the light what we do is we record not
color information but depth information
exactly as we would do in normal
rendering in other words we render into
the depth buffer and we record at every
pixel exactly how far away every pixel
is from the point of view of the light
and we saved that information in a
buffer fog use later then when we come
to render the scene from the point of
view of the camera we take this point
here and we project it out of world
space where it is into light space so
what we know then is exactly how far
away the point that we're shading is
from the point of view of the light what
we can then do is do a lookup into the Z
buffer from the light pass that we
rendered before and we can find out how
far away that point is from the light
and compare it to the value in the Z
buffer so in this case we find that the
depth from the light at this point is
further than the depth from the front
face of the pyramid here
therefore it's in shadow and we don't
need to do our lighting here or we need
to incorporate that information into our
lighting equations so if we add another
line that's not done anything it's all
but in theory we can have as many whites
as we like
but plenty anyway yeah so in theory we
can have as many whites as we like as
long as we are prepared to render the
scene again and again from the point of
view of every light so that we have
enough information when we come to shade
in the pixels to be able to do that lock
up and say is this pixel in shadow from
this particular light or is it being
illuminated and in modern games and
things like that now we can have
multiple lights because we can afford to
render the scene multiple times from
multiple perspectives in order to build
up that that information however if you
look back just maybe 10 or 15 years at
all during games and things like that
you tend only to have one shadow casting
light or maybe not even any at all
because rendering or hundreds of
thousands of triangles every single
frame is expensive in terms of time and
so it's sometimes better just to accept
the quality loss and not have any
shadows rather than go go for complete
realism and often naturally you find
that a single shadow looks much better
than no shadows at all but two or three
shadows only looks marginally better
than one shadow it is a law of
diminishing returns
we'd like to thank audible.com for their
support of this computer valve video and
if you'd like to download one of their
huge range of books go to audible.com
slash computer file and you can sign up
and download one for free I'd like to
recommend a book called bad science by
Ben Goldacre and for those of you
interested in science it's fantastic
it shows how science is misused in the
media and debunk some common interesting
practice such as homeopathy that's my
favorite part so gallant audible.com
slash computerphile
sign up download a free book and thanks
to them again for supporting this
computerphile video and when you click
that go button so I'm not going to my
awesome blog it goes to the really badly
designed online bank which promptly says
oh and in general it works because the
majority of scenes
compose mostly of opaque objects that
are amenable to Zed testing